معنا الآن هو Rocha dal الرئيس
والمدير التنفيذي لجمعية السفر الأمريكية
وقد حضر اجتماع الصناعة يوم الثلاثاء
مع نائب الرئيس مايك بنس ، ومن الجيد أن
تكون معنا ،
مرحبًا ليندا ، كيف حالك جيدًا
بالنظر إلى الظروف مع الأخذ في
الاعتبار أنني أريد الحصول على رأيك
هذا لأن بعض الاقتصاديين الذين أعتقد
أنهم متفائلون تمامًا قالوا
إن هذه الأزمة تشبه أحداث 11 سبتمبر
وسوف نتعافى بسرعة لكننا سمعنا
من الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة يونايتد إيرلاينز الذي
كتب إلى الكونجرس ويقول إن هذا
سيكون  أسوأ بكثير من 11 سبتمبر
ويريدون إنقاذ مدى الضرر الذي يمكن أن تحصل عليه ، حيث
يمكن أن تصبح سيئًا للغاية ، فنحن ننظر في
صناعة السفر وحدها ثلاثمائة
وخمسة وخمسون مليار دولار حيث
الخسارة الآن 800 مليار أخرى
للاقتصاد الأمريكي  سيكون 4.6 مليون
عامل في صناعة السفر عاطلين عن
العمل ، وأوافق على أهمية
الحفاظ على استمرارية شركات الطيران ، لكن عليك
أن تضع في اعتبارك أنهم يمثلون
حوالي 15٪ من صناعة السفر  لذلك ،
لا يقتصر الأمر على شركات الطيران فحسب ، بل يشمل جميع
الأشخاص ، والفنادق ، والمتنزهات الترفيهية ،
ومراكز المؤتمرات ، كل ما
يشكل السفر والسياحة أمر مهم للغاية
لأننا نستمر في المضي قدمًا بشكل مطلق ، وأن هذا
الرقم الذي ذكرته والذي يبلغ 4.6 مليون شخص
تتحدث عن وظائف هنا و  إذا
حدث ذلك ، فسوف يضاعف
معدل البطالة في الولايات المتحدة ، فقد قمت بتشغيل
هذه الأرقام بوضوح من قبل
الإدارة ، فما هو ردهم ،
وكيف سيساعدون الصناعة
خاصة بالنظر إلى أن
لدينا بالفعل عجزًا قياسيًا قابلناه
بالأمس  سبعة أعضاء من صناعة الفنادق ،
اثنان من صناعة المنتزهات
، وقد التقينا مع الرئيس ترامب
نائب الرئيس بنس ووزير
التجارة ويلبر روس ونقدم
هذه الأرقام ويفهمونها
بوضوح شديد ، كان الرئيس
ملتزمًا تمامًا بكلماته نحن
سنهاجم هذا بطريقة كبيرة بطريقة رئيسية
وسنفعل كل ما نحتاج
إلى القيام به للعمال وكان هذا هو كل
شيء لدينا  يجب أن نتأكد من أن
هؤلاء العمال لا يجلسون
ويجمعون البطالة أو لا يقومون بتحصيل الأموال ،
وعلينا التأكد من حصول هؤلاء
الأشخاص على رواتبهم والأهم من ذلك
أن الشركات يمكنها الحفاظ على الأضواء
بحيث تضع التصاريح للجميع  العودة إلى
العمل لا يريد الأشخاص بدوام كامل أن يفقدوا
موظفيهم هناك ، فهم
مدربون جيدًا على ما يفعلونه